can you explain
the fundamentals of jiu-jitsu yes if i
couldn't
i wouldn't be much of a coach um
jiu-jitsu is an art and science which
looks to use
a combination of tactical
and mechanical advantage to focus
a very high percentage of my strength
against a very
low percentage of my opponent's strength
at a critical point
on their body such that if i were to
exert my strength upon that critical
point
they could no longer continue to fight
well that's about weapons and defenses
but then is there something more to be
said about the set of tools
that are that we're talking about that's
where the art comes in
because ultimately you have a set of
choices and those choices that you make
will be
an act of self-expression on your part
some will prefer
this some will prefer that that's where
you come in as an individual
that's an overall definition of
jiu-jitsu
of being a set of choices
that where you're
using the things you're powerful in
versus the things your opponent
is weak in no i was only talking about
percentages of body strength if i have
for example let's say um we have two
athletes athlete a and athlete b
athlete a has 100 units of strength
however we define that overall
athlete b has 50. okay so ostensibly
athlete a is twice as strong as athlete
b
but athlete b can maneuver his body
into a set of positions
focused around a critical point of his
opponent's body
where he can apply 40 units of strength
out of his total of 50.
his opponent can only defend with 20
units of strength out of his total
of 100 you have now completely reversed
the strange discrepancy originally
athlete a was twice as strong as b
now on that one localized point the knee
the elbow the neck
b is now twice as strong as a under
those circumstances
b should win i guess what i'm trying to
get at by the way that's really
beautifully said
is what you just said could be applied
to
other games other battles it could be
applied to the game of chess
uh it could be applied to war most
obviously in war
i think about for example um
the american strategic bombing campaign
in world war ii
uh the 8th army air force was tasked
with the idea of destroying german
industry
did they attack all of german industry
of course not
that would be stupid they attacked the
ball bearing industry
why because almost all
of modern machines require ball bearings
in order to operate
in order for the mechanical interfaces
of machines to operate you have to
reduce friction it's done through ball
bearings
if you knocked out one tiny component
of german industry the ball bearing
industry the rest of it
couldn't operate so too with the human
body i don't have to fight your whole
body
i just have to fight your left knee if i
can break your left knee the rest of
your body is irrelevant to me
but then isn't the art of jujitsu
discovering the the left knee
the discovering the weak points you know
a huge part of judas who is
understanding the weak strengths and
weaknesses of the human body
it's parts of the human body that are
shockingly robust
and there are other parts that are
shockingly vulnerable the major joints
and of course the most vulnerable of all
the unprotected neck
so if we take the something i'm not
familiar with but i was incredibly
impressed by is the body lock
that i saw um
nick rodriguez nick rodriguez used uh
last time a few weeks ago yes but then i
also got to hang out with craig jones
who
also has a very good body lock so that
that was uh i don't know if this body
lock applies to all positions but i was
seeing it from when craig is uh
on top of your opponent
and trying to pass the passing the guard
use the body lock as a controlling
position
the the principle behind it is that it
shuts down
as you've spoken about it shuts down
the weapons of a very strong opponent
that's absolutely correct in the case of
um
guard position what makes guard position
dangerous what makes someone a powerful
guard player
is the movement of their hips forward
and backward and side to side
body locking is designed to shut down
that movement
and does a very fine job of it you'll
see all of my students accelerate gordon
ryan is
probably the single best body dog car
passer i've ever seen nikki ryan is
outstanding with it
nick rodriguez is very good craig jones
is outstanding
all of my students use this for a very
simple reason
understand what is the central problem
of shutting down a
dangerous guard player it's his hips
that's what makes him a dangerous leg
locker you go up against the dangerous
leg lock him
body lock guard pass single best way to
shut down
most of his entries um
we're all strong in leg locks so in our
gym
you gotta control the hips as soon as
possible he's gonna otherwise it's gonna
be a very difficult thing to avoid
leg entanglements as you go to parts and
uh
uh across the board my students excel in
in
uh in body lock guard passing
they understand what's the most
dangerous feature their opponent has the
lateral movement of their hips
what's the single best way to stop that
body lock and then
work from there
you